das hier ist für mich das beste
schnitzelbrötchen der Welt wie saftig
einfach wir machen katsu Sando dafür
brauchen wir erstmal Hähnchenbrust das
huh habe ich jetzt in so feine Scheiben
geschnitten und jetzt knete ich das mit
ein bisschen Misopaste durch müsst ihr
nicht machen ist optional aber boostet
den Geschmack noch mal ordentlich durch
dann nehmen wir unser chicken und legen
das erstmal in Mehl dann geben wir es in
Ei und es dann anschließend in penco
breadcumbs zu geben und dann können wir
es auch direkt schon Frittieren für die
Soße Ketchup Zucker eusters saauce und
jede Menge westerser Soße jetzt heiß
werden lassen umrühren bis es zu einer
Soße wird und so schnell hat man tonkatu
Soße jetzt guckt euch mal dieses chicken
hier an einfach nur geil dann können wir
uns jetzt ein Sandwich nehmen auf eine
Seite geben wir cololdslaw wie man den
macht habe ich euch letztens schon
gezeigt das ist wirklich der geilste
cololdsla den ich kenne ein schönen
Crunch saftig einfach geil auf die
andere Seite kommt ordentlich tonkotzu
Soße dann kommt unser chicken Zack und
jetzt fürs Auge einmal den Rand
abschneiden dann hält man diese
perfekten Ecken aber selbstverständlich
ist man das auch m boah